we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail about mail-in voting a very
important topic this election cycle take
a listen hey we need to push the mail-in
vote regardless of what he says in
numbers we need to push the mail vote
absolutely agree
listen twenty twenty could come down to
mail in voting we we just don't know
what the state of the pandemic is going
to be in november if the numbers
continue to decline between now and then
we could have a safe ish situation to go
out and vote in person in november but
there are still going to be people that
will be scared and rightfully so because
we are not going to eradicate this in
any significant way maybe ever i mean it
might become just a seasonal thing where
you have to manage it with a seasonal
coronavirus vaccine we just don't know
but it will still be here in some
capacity in november if we are in the
middle of a second wave in november then
waiting on setting up vote-by-mail is
going to be too late there will be
states who won't be able to do it it'll
be a disaster so the caller could not be
more right we need to be pushing for
vote-by-mail now unfortunately some
states are doing it now even places like
texas at least for now are allowing
anybody who wants an absentee ballot to
get an absentee ballot and it's valid to
say the reason i want one is i'm afraid
of getting coronavirus that is valid
even in texas right now but depending on
the numbers by november it may no longer
apply to the November presidential
election understand that trump has no
federal authority to ban vote-by-mail
Trump also has no federal authority to
designate churches essential
organizations or whatever the case may
be but that doesn't mean Trump isn't
going to run propaganda on this he's
already been pushing vote-by-mail leads
to voter fraud it's not true the data
don't suggest it don't demonstrate it in
any way whatsoever but we are starting
to see local Republican officials take a
cue from Trump
and start to say it causes fraud it
opens the door to fraud bla bla bla bla
bla let's not allow them to do that
let's lobby all of our states to say at
minimum it doesn't we're not saying
right now cancel in-person voting we're
just we don't need to do that all we
need is a rule that says if you want to
vote by mail you can and you will not
have to justify it because you're out of
state you will not you can just request
an absentee ballot period better is we
will send everyone an application for an
absentee ballot which they have to
return to get an absentee ballot even
better is we will send everyone an
actual absentee ballot now different
states have different rules about what's
allowed in terms of automatically
sending people absentee ballots versus
well you can't do that you've got to
send them an application every state is
different it's a patchwork of 50
different elections let's go for the
gold which is send everybody an absentee
ballot and let them vote by mail if not
send everybody an absentee ballot
application if not let everybody request
an absentee ballot for any reason even
if it doesn't meet the previously
established requirements for why one
would get an absentee ballot we can do
this and one last thing on this I'm
spending more time on this than I
planned to but this is important it only
really matters in a few states right I
mean listen California whether they vote
by mail or not
Biden's gonna win California
Massachusetts Biden's going to win
Massachusetts Utah Trump's going to win
Utah I think although I actually saw one
poll which says it's not as out of reach
for Biden as you might imagine but
Trump's likely going to going to win
Utah we need to focus our efforts in
particular states Republicans know this
right we're talking about Pennsylvania
Florida Ohio Michigan Wisconsin I'm not
getting all of them that's where we need
to focus our efforts we've got a
fantastic bonus show for you today I
will recap my appearance on the Joe
Rogan experience last week I have a new
rabbit problem you are not going to
believe what I have dealt with over the
last 48 hours some of you will some of
you won't and also we will talk about a
rat problem
rats are finding less trash to eat be
because a lot of commercial spaces that
generate huge amounts of trash are
essentially closed not generating trash
rats are becoming cannibalistic because
of the trash shortage due to coronavirus
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show don't miss it
sign up at join pakman.com and I will
see you then